can egypt's leaders be pressured into
protecting press freedom
al jazeera condemns the 15-year jail
sentence given to one of its journalists
for interviewing an opposition leader so
why is egypt silencing critical voices
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim zhum al-jazeera is
condemning the 15-year jail sentence
given in egypt to one of the network's
journalists according cairo's ahmed taha
in his absence for what prosecutors
called spreading false news taha is a
presenter for al-jazeera's mubashir news
channel and says the ruling won't deter
him from doing his job
he was charged for interviewing egyptian
opposition leader and former
presidential candidate
four years ago al-jazeera says the
verdict was irrational unjustified and
part of egypt's continued campaign
against the network and its journalists
the network's demanding the release of
four other al-jazeera journalists
detained in egypt without charge
is here with me in the studio ahmed
thank you so much for joining us today
on inside story we really appreciate it
let me ask you first what does this
verdict and sentence mean for you as a
journalist what does it mean for the
network and what in your opinion does it
mean for the overall state of press
freedom
at the beginning i would like to thank
you for having me
this court ruling represents
means a lot at all levels
as mentioned in your questions i'm still
in a total shock i woke up in the
morning to find myself sentenced to 15
years in prison simply for doing my job
as a tv presenter what i did is had an
interview with a public figure in egypt
one of the leaders of the official
political party and one of the
presidential candidates it was uh
he was also
accused in this false trial and was
sentenced
similarly i interviewed him in 2018 to
update the viewers on the latest
development and the political situation
in egypt i found myself
the subject of a kangaroo
trial sentenced to 15 years without any
legal notification without even having
the chance to get represented by a
lawyer
above all there is
no
legal procedures measures the standard
legal rules are totally violated it is
a totally kangaroo
trial
um
this
court ruling is exceptional root adopted
by the political regime in egypt it is
one of the political one of the
political tools
against
freedom of
oppression and freedom of press
it is a shameful
ruling to me i believe this ruling is
not directed against me it is directed
at al jazeera as a media network uh it's
again it's the values and principle al
jazeera represents
it is directed against the freedom of
press
al jazeera is simply
a beacon for
knowledge and freedom that's why i
repeat this ruling is shameful and when
the history of this
the history of
press in this region is written a total
chapter will be dedicated to me a
journalist like me
being tried under false trial and
sentenced to jail
simply for doing his job it is a shame
about this verdict and this sentence
being used as a political tool do you or
does the network have any legal recourse
to try to either appeal or overturn it
unfortunately i contacted a number of
lawyers
and
they said this
court ruling was handed down by an
exceptional
court panel and there is no rule
for us to
challenge the judgment
and it is totally a political trial and
i believe the normal standard
proceedings
of taking the courts are absent in this
yesterday i was speaking to my fellow
colleagues and i told them it is a clear
crystal clear situation
murdering
logic
again this is a shameful ruling it is
a clear representation of the ongoing
campaign against al jazeera and its
journalists we have four of our fellow
colleagues who have been detained for
more than three years
they have been detained without any
charge pressing pressed against them and
without
committing any crime they were detained
simply because they are part of al
jazeera media since you brought them up
i also wanted to ask you about that the
fact that we have four of our colleagues
that are still in detention being held
without charge what do you think that
this verdict and sentence means when it
comes to their cases
we had thought that there is uh
way out
as the regime in egypt spoke about
a possible
release of
prisoners of conscience when we had
hoped that our four colleagues will be
included however after this
unjust ruling handed down against me
our hope
has receded
now we are certain
that all what has been propagated by the
egyptian regime over the past
period of time is false
i believe
that the regime is egypt is responsible
for the unjust attention of our four
colleagues i repeat those colleagues did
not violate any rules they did not
commit
any crime and egypt is a signatory to
all the international conventions uh
regarding the freedom of
press and that's why i call on the
egyptian authorities to release our
colleagues immediately without delay and
the shameful ruling handed down against
me not only against me again is the
freedom of press in general should be
scrapped thank you so much for taking
the time to speak to us today about
what's happened to you what's happening
to our four colleagues who are still
being held without charge and to other
journalists in egypt we really
appreciate it
egypt's president launched a national
strategy for human rights last september
but rights groups dismissed it as a
deceptive attempt to show reforms are
happening to the international community
other al jazeera journalists have been
targeted and detained in egypt
mahmoud hussein was released last year
after a four-year prison sentence he was
arrested in 2016 while visiting
relatives in cairo but was never
formally charged with a crime or put on
trial
in 2013 al jazeera journalist
mohammed fahemi and peter griezte were
jailed for what egypt called spreading
false news they were released after a
year but seven colleagues were sentenced
to 10 years
in his press freedom index reporters
without borders ranks egypt at 168 out
of 180 countries and says at least 21
journalists remain imprisoned in
egypt all right let's bring in our
guests in washington dc sharif monsoor
middle east and north africa program
coordinator at the committee to protect
journalists
in the u.s city of minneapolis muhammad
al-musli chair of the journalism program
at the doha institute for graduate
studies
and in brussels hussein byumi egypt and
libya researcher at amnesty
international a warm welcome to you all
and thanks so much for joining us today
on inside story shadif let me start with
you today how many journalists are
jailed and detained in egypt and what
kind of message does this 15-year
sentence that was given to ahmad send to
journalists there
yeah thank you for having me i think
according to our most recent count it's
20 journalists one of them was order
released while we're still waiting today
to see him released so it will bring the
count down
from 25 in december which is a good sign
it means that at least
the repression machine is slowing down
we're seeing more
releases than arrests since last year
but it doesn't mean that the repression
machine was dismantled
or that there will be any legislative or
executive action
to limit
the egyptian government's
ability to imprison journalists in the
short term
we think there are improvement in terms
of the numbers but
egypt's still the third worst jailer of
journalists today
and
that has been the case for at least
eight years under president abdel fattah
sisi
so we need to see a lot more if we think
that the verdict we saw today
is
is something that as an exception
actually it is the norm still in egypt
where we see the worst condition for
press freedom
in egypt's modern history
hussein
egypt's president abdel fattah sisi
launched a national strategy for human
rights uh this was done last september
but rights groups uh have basically
dismissed this as a as an attempt a
deceptive attempt to show that reforms
are happening to the international
community
the fact that
was sentenced in absentia months after
this national strategy for human rights
was announced what does this say to you
what does that mean
uh from our point of view
we are seeing that the authorities
continue to arbitrarily arrest opponents
and critics uh including journalists
since april or at least three
journalists were um arrested as a
verdict
against uh
ahmed was a clear example says asian
authorities have no intention of easing
pressure instead they are shifting to uh
different strategies where we are seeing
the release of some
well-known
detainees avoiding high profile
arrests and instead focusing more and
more on people that the government can
label as pro-muslim brotherhood or in
some way connected to the muslim
brotherhood but overall we are not
seeing improvement in terms of
enjoyment rights including freedom
is there anything that could be done by
any international actors that would that
would make
egypt mitigate its treatment of
journalists and activists and dissidents
i guess what i'm asking is can egypt's
leaders be pressured into protecting
press freedom
well
international
activists
researchers scholars have
been calling on the international
community really since 2013
to put pressure on the egyptian
regime unfortunately there's been
a lot of reluctance there's been a lack
of
willingness on the part of key
international actors to do
anything substantial uh to answer your
question i i do think it is it is
possible i mean the united states could
speak volumes if they
actually uh withheld aid uh from from
egypt for instance that's just one
example but the united states government
hasn't really
showed uh hasn't shown any serious
willingness to to do to do much other
than you know sort of pay lip service to
um you know concepts associated with
with human rights and freedom and
democracy and so on and so forth and
issuing the occasional uh you know slap
on the wrist uh to the to the
uh regime but um you know the regime is
concerned about its international image
uh they're concerned about uh pressure
that could be applied uh they've tried
to to um
put on this facade of of you know
democratic uh reform um
largely because they are concerned uh
but as i said uh to date there just
hasn't been anything meaningful that has
been done by by any uh international
actor
sharif muhammad there was talking about
the the aid that the u.s gives to egypt
and how perhaps that could be leveraged
into getting egypt to act differently
when it comes to dissident voices
critical voices journalists
i want to ask you specifically about
that relationship the u.s gives egypt
1.3 billion dollars in military aid
annually
the u.s congress put human rights
related conditions on 300 million
dollars of that 1.3 billion dollars
in january the biden administration
announced that it had cancelled 130
million dollars of that 300 million in
military aid to egypt because of human
rights concerns the state department
said that egypt had not met the
conditions to receive that aid but in
the grand scheme of things if you're
talking about
130 million out of what is essentially
1.3 billion per year is that an amount
that would compel
egyptian president assisi to actually do
anything to improve the human rights
situation in egypt
absolutely it's one factor i think that
goes into the relationship that defines
much of what president el-sisi wants
and i think there are other factors put
together that can
improve at least
the situation
and i think one of them is meeting
here in washington dc
president
and sisi have not had an oval office
meeting for a year and a half
and that's
also a big factor in the upcoming trip
with president biden going into the
region and trying to extract as much
concessions
across
the region
in his planned agenda
so these are two factors and the aid
conditionality i think there is a lot
more improvement in terms of how
congress
is able to exert pressure that has to do
with something the administration have
also said which is protecting
dissidents abroad including u.s citizens
and that's i think one thing we can see
in the air conditionality there are a
lot more specificity about it and also
with
talks of public officials from dubai
administration
and that's i think what the main idea
about behind the sentencing is that the
exiled voices those have
people have been able to
basically shut down any conversation
inside egypt borders so the remaining
voices outside become more critical
including al jazeera regionally but also
internationally out of the us here so i
think
yes it matters to president sisi having
that meeting it also matters to him what
he saw recently was
for the first time the us uh justice
department indicting and uh
a spy for the egyptian intelligence here
that they wanted to spy on dissidents
out of new york and that was something i
think that sent a lot more messages
about possibility of other impunitive
measures like sanctions
under magnitsky sanctions or sanctions
are the khashoggi
bans that we have seen this
administration introduce
uh hussein of course we've seen the
statement from amnesty international
condemning this verdict and other
verdicts as well and sentences um if we
could just take a step back for a moment
zoom out for a bit why is egypt
silencing critical voices well the
egyptian authorities are silencing
critical
voices because they don't believe or
they don't want to see
voices that oppose the government it's
that simple from the point of view of
security
forces but right now is that what led to
the fall of mubarak
governments government's regime was a
limited space of
freedoms that he gave so the concern is
from the security agency's point of view
right now is that any criticism can very
easily snowball into major street
protests that in turn would endanger
stability
of
regime or government depending on who
you ask of course
but this essentially is the issue is
that in order to
prevent any sort of
effective opposition security forces
have been silencing all
the critical voices and you see that for
example in targeting not just um you
know not just major uh political
opponents but really going after
individuals over facebook
posts going after um lawyers for example
which is also assigned as the
authorities want to further prevent
lawyers and prevent
others from reporting violations that
are happening
in the country so most recently we saw
the arrest of yusuf monsoor uh 20 uh
lawyer in his twenties simply because he
posted uh on his social media page about
um
and now he's detained pending
investigation over terrorism and charges
so in short the government really
doesn't prosecute isis in particular see
any sort of criticism as a big or as a
first step towards anti-government
mobilization
muhammad i want to talk more
specifically for a moment about the
sentence that was given to ahmad taha
this is a 15-year jail sentence that was
given in absentia for spreading false
news over a 2018 interview with abdomen
he's a leading opposition figure and
former presidential candidate in egypt
himself was sentenced to 15 years in
jail this week over accusations of
plotting against the state
even in a country where
the jailing and sentencing of of
journalists and dissidents has become
quite common
does this action this sentencing of
ahmed taha to 15 years
in jail for this interview does that not
seem excessive
well i mean what doesn't uh
seem excessive you know uh
cc came to power
in 2013 on the back of a military coup
uh the violence that was carried out at
the time was was excessive there were
five large-scale massacres of civilians
carried out in the summer of 2013.
the regime went on to eliminate all
forms of political opposition they
arrested tens of thousands of people
including political leaders they banned
all of the key opposition parties they
shut down all of the key opposition news
outlets so you know what in that was it
wasn't excessive so you know um this is
this is an extreme authoritarian regime
so while it's shocking to us that that a
journalist could be uh you know uh
sentenced to 15 years in jail for
quote-unquote false news spreading false
news just for asking some questions in
an interview really it's entirely uh
consistent with with uh with the the
sisi regime's uh modis uh apparanda and
i just wanted to piggyback on uh what mr
bayumi was saying on the previous
question
you know in terms of you know why the
regime acts out the way that it does
this is a very scared very paranoid
regime in addition to the things that i
just mentioned about eliminationism
you know we have to remember that assisi
is deeply insecure
a few people tried to
you know put their names in the hat
and run against him
in the presidential election a few years
ago and he arrested them uh or otherwise
eliminated them so that just underscored
the extent to which uh he's he's
insecure and that's one of the reasons
why
egypt does not tolerate
any sign of dissent whatsoever i thought
philip luther
amnesty's middle eastern north africa
director said it best a couple of years
ago when he said the egyptian
authorities have made it very clear that
anyone who challenges the official
narrative will be severely uh punished
and if there's an opportunity i think we
should talk at some point today about um
nabila makram uh who
is the immigration minister who
threatened egyptians abroad
with death
a few years back in in a speech in in
canada
saying that any egyptian who speaks
against the state who criticizes the
government uh could be could be killed
could be sliced up uh in her in her
words
shadi
what legal justification is there for
egyptian courts to dole out these kinds
of verdicts and sentences what is the
rationale that they are going by and
also from your point of view is there
any space that currently exists in egypt
for for opposition or for dissent or for
critical voices
well not at all i think what what we saw
is the same promises that lccc have
given over and over and never delivered
on
we might see
some gestures just to
allow
some of those
things to happen
this year including while they host the
international environment
conference in uh sharmishir in september
of course it's an opportunity for the
government to try and get gain some
support as it tackles its economic uh
challenges and immediate threats
so of course there is an opening an
opportunity that can materialize but
those are legal battles that
no one has control of because they are
happening in emergency
courts
those who have issued even death penalty
against some al jazeera journalists in
the past and some who continue to be
jailed today
in pretrial detention without three
course without evidence some for four
years or more so yes there isn't any
legal ability to find justice within
egypt's border and that's why many
people are demanding justin to happen uh
in a political price or even in u.s
courts or
european parliament courts not just in
congress and in other ways so yes we
want to see a lot more uh focus on the
right of dissidence approval but also
shed light on people who do not get even
the attention that al jazeera
journalists have there are four more
jesus journalists who are imprisoned in
egypt today
but there are so many who do not even
have
any affiliation with an outlet let alone
a regional or an international one
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thank you so much to
all of our guests sharif mansour
muhammad al-masri and
and thanks to
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim joel the whole team here
bye for now
you